and his royal hand is the prince of
wales leading the royal family to their
position
as we prepare for the national
act of remembrance here
at the cenotaph
this is sky news you're watching the
national act of remembrance from london
we will remember them
[Music]
[Music]
uh
alright
[Music]
foreign
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my
[Music]
the buglers at the royal marines playing
the last post
and lieutenant colonel tom white of the
royal marines
aquarius to her majesty the queen gives
her majesty's wreath to the prince of
wales
on behalf of her majesty
and the nation
he lays it
his own wreath as our apparent and
prince of wales
given to him by major jonathan thompson
bearing on it the
symbol of the
three feathers
all prince of wales and our apparent
watched by his wife the duchess of
cambridge
the duke of cambridge will
place his wreath also beside that of her
majesty
the earth of wessex
wearing the cavalry cloak of the royal
wessex urinary
reminder of the armed forces being made
up of regulars
and reserves
in all three services
heroin highness the princess royal
who was promoted
to the rank of general
in the army and our chief marshall
dressed today as
admiral in the royal navy
and on behalf of the duke of kent whose
father's was killed in the second world
war
his aquarium captain james calder smith
of the scots guards
will lay the last of the royal reeds
the parade will now be stood at ease
hey
stood easy beethoven's tune the funeral
march
as the prime minister
on behalf
of her majesty's government
will lay his wreath
[Music]
the leader of her majesty's opposition
the right honorable secure stammer
on behalf of the labour party
[Music]
you